Hey Youtubers it's Charlie happy Friday surprise
surprise there's new Star Wars footage so
lets break it down.
The really big thing with this trailer is
that it is expanding on some of the scenes
we saw on the last trailer and I think we
get a little bit of Gwendolyn Christie dialogue
a little bit of Captain Phasma.
we do know that person in the opening scene
now is Lupita the Maz Canata character so
looks like she's going to be something of
a guide for Reys character but I do like the
extra context for Kylo Ren like we see him
activate his lightsaber on the star destroyer
here and then again later when he's fighting
with raised character which looks like it's
connected to this scene here where she grabs
the blaster like right after maybe this person
has died this place here we know now this
is one of the new rebel bases or resistance
base, technically the rebel alliance is called
the resistance in episode seven just like
the Empire has become the first order we get
some new shots of the falcon especially chewie
here here, looks at the blowing up a base
return of the Jedi in a show shield generator
style a little bit more Princess Leia not
so much with Poe Dameron I'm surprised we
haven't seen more of him in the trailers and
without obviously what I can to see Luke they
said that they made a conscious choice not
to include him in the marketing materials
so so don't expect to see Luke on any of the
posters or in any of the trailers that sounds
weird but they don't want you to forget about
the original trilogy characters there the
big stars right now the way to focus on the
new characters so there's the minimizing the
presence of the classic Trinity but from what
the trailers are telling us it looks like
Han Solo and chewy are fairly critical to
what's going on early on in the movie I'm
guessing the Luke Skywalker doesn't show up
so much much later there was some promotional
material fanning the Ray Jedi theories but
I like the idea here that she's running into
battle grabbing her staff I as have a feeling
she's going to be doing some really bad as
staff fighting for most of the movie that
really says nothing about her for sensitivity
and I think it is certain point the forcible
awaken in her like there's the reference at
the end of the trailer to a new hope she's
kind of a Luke Skywalker character even though
I think that Finn is, that to she and Finn
kind of share that Luke Skywalker persona
little Bit Is Way, Luke is a new hope in episode
four the hope represented by new characters
in a twist in a battle this battle here looks
like it's going to be a VR version of battlefront
like the way you wish it would look the speaking
of the battles BlizzCon starts today in is
going to be a warcraft trailer posting in
a couple hours I'm totally going to do video
for it, so be sure to subscribe to get that
even if the you haven't played warcraft in
a while it is gonna be so much fun while you
guys wait for more warcraft you can click
here to watch my last Star Wars trailer video
just enter the infinite loop just watch them
over and over and over and you can click here
for the warcraft teaser trailer if you haven't
seen it yet.
Thank you so much for watching, everybody
let's high five and I'll see you in a little
bit!